hi good morning everyone
and welcome to the video on introduction
to cyber security
my name is bibin kulkarni and we'll be
discussing what exactly cyber security
is and how it affects our day-to-day
work lives but before we begin with the
details of cyber security let's consider
this
as an example in an office one day quinn
who is following his daily routine
working on his computer trying to crunch
the numbers work his data through
but in the background without his
knowledge there is a hacker who is
trying to access the confidential files
located on quinn's computer through a
vulnerability the hacker is able to
access those files
and he or she then transfers those files
back to the hacker's computer so what
can happen due to this
legal ramifications to the business loss
of
company secrets leakage of information
uh maybe
industrial espionage which basically
means a competitor
is trying to analyze a company a
company's secrets
and trying to gain access to their data
or they could hold the company for
ransom
and ask them for money or sell it to
criminals who can further
dilute the information or misuse that
information for the criminal activities
anything is possible so it's a very bad
scenario if a hacker gets access
to the company secrets so what is it
that we're going to
discuss in this video to start off with
we're going to talk about
what is cyber security then we are going
to talk about why cyber security is
necessary in today's world
how does it work who is a cyber security
expert what are the skills required
and of course what the courses and
certifications required
from an individual to be called a cyber
security expert
so let's begin with the first one what
is cyber security
cyber security by itself is a process a
design and architecture
created to protect networks and devices
from attacks
damage or unauthorized access so the
advantages of cyber security
are that you want to protect your
business like in the previous example
we just talked about an individual and
his files being accessed what if
company server got compromised or their
web applications got compromised and the
databases leaked out
so we want to protect our businesses
from hackers which will result in
increased productivity because people
would then be
in a very controlled environment
concentrating more on their work
than worrying about cyber criminals it
would inspire considerable confidence
uh where if i as an organization i'm
going to
audit myself i'm going to ensure that
i'm complying to
certain regulations my clients would
feel more confident about sharing their
information with me as an organization
it will help me making my applications
and websites more stable
protect them from external threats and
would also protect my customers or
clients from cyber attacks
because i would be holding some amount
of data for my customers and clients as
well so i have to think about not only
my organization the data that my
organization owns
but what i held or what i hold for my
customers and clients as well
so essentially what we want to achieve
out of here is
a design which we want to implement in a
manner
which will allow all these factors to
function
in a standardized manner so why do we
want this and what would be the
advantages of implementing cyber
security
now first and foremost what is cyber
security there are three
main pillars of cyber security that we
deal with since
the inception of computers and they're
known as the confidentiality
integrity and availability triad also
known as cia
not to be confused with the american
intelligence agency but
here we're looking at three different
pillars where we want our data to remain
confidential
the integrity of the data to be intact
and the data to be made available
at all points in time so let's talk
about
these three aspects the principle of
confidentiality
asserts that the information and
functions can be accessed only by
authorized parties
so for example even if you password
protect your file what is it that you're
trying to
do you're trying to prevent other users
accessing your data
and peeping into your files so that your
data remains confidential
it is only shared with people who know
the password
integrity this is where the
trustworthiness of that data comes into
the picture
where if the data is going to be changed
for example
you have a spreadsheet which has a lot
of information about users
and their login activities and whatnot
and you want to ensure that that data is
not modified by any unauthorized user
so you're going to verify that the
information is correct
and is not modified by anybody
who is unauthorized the availability
part ensures that this data is made
available
to all authorized users when and where
they want it
right the principles of availability
assert that in systems functions and
data must be available
on demand according to agreed upon
parameters based on levels of service
now this is where your service level
agreement should come in for example
when we log on to gmail we always assume
that gmail is going to work and it's
going to be available online
at no point in time or very few times
has it ever occurred that you've gone on
to the internet typed in gmail.com and
the website is not available
in fact if the website doesn't open we
figure out the internet is not working
right but gmail as a service is always
made available
now when we talk about threats to cia
the confidentiality integrity and
availability we talk about them in two
different parameters cyber crime and
hacking
so what is cyber crime cyber crime is
any criminal activity or any
unauthorized activity that would involve
the usage of any computing device which
would result
as a security incident at the victim's
end
most cyber crimes are carried out in
order to profit from them
criminals would try to do phishing
attacks to steal your money out of your
bank accounts or who try to con you into
giving out your credentials
thus compromising your email accounts or
your social media accounts
and try to gain access to your identity
cyber crimes are generally carried out
against computers or devices directly to
damage or disable them
spread malware secret and steal secret
information etc
so this talks about the motivation part
of cyber crimes what would be the
motivational aspect
for a person to conduct such an activity
right so basically to cause damage like
wannacry happened in 2017
the perpetrators those those used
wannacry
probably gained a lot in the ransom that
they demanded for that data to be
decrypted but it also cost
the world a lot of money in profits that
were lost
so let's talk about types of cyber crime
the first type is a computer assisted
crime
where the computers are used as tools to
assist a particular crime
for example frauds or online bank
hijacking
where hackers hack into a bank and
digitally steal
money from a bank now this could have
happened without the help of computers
as well but here
computer assisted the crime and hence it
would fall under the computer-assisted
crime section
the second part is where the computer
itself was a target of a crime for
example a denial of service attack
or viruses which rendered the computer
useless or sniffing of data packets on
the network thus compromising
passwords and other confidential
information the third is
a computer which is incidental to the
crime so here the computer was used as a
temporary measure to store some data
such as child pornography
or some other some other data which made
the computer incidental
to the crime all right let's look at a
business scenario for cyber security
there is a quiz at the end so please
listen up and pay attention
there's this company called stock
industries and one day
most of the employees have started
reporting that their systems have either
crashed
or have started hanging so the id
security team comes in
does the investigation tries to find out
what uh what exactly went wrong and they
have identified that an employee
has clicked on a suspicious link now
these links could either
be received as an email or via an email
through social media like facebook or
somebody sending out a skype chat
and attachments within skype now once a
user clicks on these links these links
are designed to redirect the connection
that the computer is going to make to a
malicious server hosted
by the hacker and it supposedly
downloads a malicious
file or some scripts and executes them
on the victim's machine
once executed the scripts or the content
within these files
maybe the content could be a virus or a
trojan these will start
executing themselves and start infecting
machines and start basically behaving
the way they have been programmed
to behave in this scenario a lot of
users started reporting that their
machine started crashing or the systems
hanged
now the security team scanned all the
systems and blocked facebook and skype
on all machines until further orders now
this is a preventive mechanism
where you're going to prevent possible
attacks of future attacks from coming in
so the reaction of the security team
here is to block
those sites from where the attack may
have happened
the question to you at this point in
time is what type of computer crime is
being referred to
in this scenario is it a computer
assisted crime computer as a target
crime
or computer incidental to the crimes so
please post your answers in the comment
sections below
and we'll respond back to you about your
answers now let's go a little bit
further and see
what would motivate people for
committing such cyber crimes
right the first and foremost motive is
disrupting business continuity
others would be looking at data theft or
information theft
and manipulating that data to gain from
that data so if i'm able to access your
computer
and steal some data that has some value
to you and sell it
or make it public you would be at a
financial loss because that data no
longer has any value
creating fear and cures by disrupting
critical infrastructure
for example a company's infrastructure
crashes the services are no longer being
offered by that organization
and people start panicking uh start
fearing an attack
bike cyber criminals and it leads to
chaos
financial loss to the target which is
very obvious if i do a denial of service
attack or if i make a service and a
variable from an organization
what is going to happen is since that
that service is not functioning
the company is not going to make any
money out of it and that's going to
suffer a financial loss achieving states
military objectives a one
country spying on another country trying
to gather information about their
military intelligence military
activities or any other activities that
can
harm the original country demanding
ransom
hackers can encrypt your data and then
demand a ransom from you
in lieu of decrypting the data again
damaging reputation of a target
impersonating a user on the social media
platforms making false statements thus
damaging the reputation of that person
and propagating religious or political
beliefs religious fanatics
promoting whatever cultures that they
want to promote
trying to gain more followers thus
bringing more unrest
to the world any of these could become
motives for cyber crime
in fact it could be just a script kitty
where people are trying to learn about
hacking
and uh they just start hacking for fun
they might not even have a motive
for making a profit out of it maybe it
just
thrills them so that they are able to
showcase their
skills and that's why they do a cyber
crime so
which brings us to the next topic where
we talk about types of hackers
this will allow us to identify what kind
of attacks are also
possible on a particular organization as
far as motives are concerned
so the basic types let's start off with
the black hat hacker individuals with
extraordinary competing skills resorting
to malicious or destructive activities
these are your criminal hackers who try
to profit from their crimes
and they will have a malicious intent in
trying to hack a victim organization
the grey hats are individuals who work
both offensively and defensively what
does that mean
they could work as black hat hackers
with malicious intent
and try to harm some organization while
on the other hand
they would also try to work as a
security analyst
and try to enhance the security posture
of an organization
for a remuneration third one which is
white hat which is what we want to be
or what we want to achieve ourselves as
an individual
who professes the same skills as a black
hat hacker probably uses the same tools
has the same kind of knowledge but the
intent is different they're going to use
them for defensive purposes
uh there's no malicious intent they act
with author authorization
from the organization and they will try
to detect any flaws and try to plug out
those flaws so that
black hat hackers would not be able to
misuse those flaws to gain
access suicide hackers now individuals
who aim to bring down critical
infrastructure for a cause
and are not worried about facing jail
terms or any other punishment so
any people uh or any organization or a
group of people
for example anonymous or these kind of
organized
hackers they have a political cause or a
social cause that they want to promote
and they
do this by hacking critical
infrastructure of organizations bring it
down
defacing their website now why would
these not be classified as blackhead
hackers the main difference between
blackhead hackers and suicide hackers is
that blackhead hackers will try to hide
their identity
they will always have a fake identity
that they will utilize
and try to hide behind it whereas
suicide hackers will claim
responsibility for the attacks that they
have done
and will post about it they will not be
worried about facing
repetitions for the attacks that they
have done the script kitty a script kid
is an unskilled hacker who compromises
systems by running scripts tools and
software's already developed and already
made available by real hackers so these
guys have
very minimal technical knowledge they
have no idea how that attack works
they're just going to use an automated
tool click on a few buttons and hope
that the attack succeeds
a cyber terrorist individual with wide
range of skills motivated by religious
or political beliefs to create fear by
large scale disruption
of computer networks we could talk about
organizations like isis who have a lot
of digital propaganda
that they use and target weak-minded
people to join their causes
or people who spread ransomware who who
terrorize organizations and hold them to
ransom
and demand money from them by encrypting
their data state-sponsored hackers
individuals employed by the government
to penetrate and gain top secret
information
and to damage information systems to
other governments the best example
would be the cyber wars that are going
on these days most of the organizations
most of the countries nowadays would
have a secret cyber cell
consisting of highly skilled hackers who
are interested with the task of spying
on the enemies
and trying to gather information by
hacking into their infrastructure
now it is not going to be a legit job it
will always be masked by a legit
organization but
this is uh this does happen hacktivism
individuals who promote a political
agenda by hacking especially defacing or
disabling websites the difference
between
suicide hackers and hacktivism is
suicide hackers
have a social cause that they want to
promote hacktivists would have a
political agenda
and they're going to deface websites and
they're going to promote their agenda by
defacing such websites
alright so let's talk about some common
attacks in cyber security
the most common attack ever seen in
today's world is a denial of service
attack
so this is where the hacker tries to
consume the resources of the victim
server in such a way that
there are no resources available for
legitimate users to connect to the
server and
conduct their business other attacks
that you will face would be malware
attacks where
there would be a malicious software that
would deliver a trojan virus or a worm
to the victim thus infecting the
victim's machine and rendering it
useless a man in the middle attack where
the hacker
would put himself in between your
machine and the router and start
sniffing data packets
that you are sending thus trying to
compromise information
contained within those packets so the
phishing attack
is where a hacker will send a seemingly
legitimate
looking message to you an email let's
say uh
asking you to perform certain actions uh
where the
hacker would be impersonating another
organization and you fall prey to that
and end up giving your confidential
information a drive by attack
cross-site scripting attacks where web
applications get compromised and scripts
are embedded within those applications
or within
commands that are sent out by the users
password attacks where your hackers try
to compromise the passwords of users
by cracking them based either on brute
force dictionary based attacks
or password guessing eavesdropping
attacks this could be physical in nature
where somebody
overhears what you're saying or tries to
capture data packets
that contain your voip transmissions
let's say you're assuming you're making
a skype
or a link based call sql injection
attacks
where again attackers will target your
database try to send in malicious
queries
which will compromise your database and
the data within but the attacks it is
based
uh on cryptography uh where there are
where you're looking at permutations and
combinations of how
algorithm functions and then you're
looking at the permutations on how many
times
the processing needs to be done for that
algorithm to be reversed
so these are some of the most common
attacks in cyber security
now uh these more than attacks would be
threats that you're going to face there
would be
various different methods that these
attacks can be launched
and that's where the cyber security
expert comes in with their knowledge
of identifying what exactly is a threat
to the organization and how they are
going to prevent that from happening
but more on that a little bit later
let's look at the history of cyber crime
so as you can see this graph shows us
how cyber crime has progressed
over the years in 1990s mnc database
pentagon and ibm were hacked
in night again in 1990s national
crackdown on criminals
microsoft nt operating system pierced so
uh this is where
hacking started becoming more mainstream
right
before this hacking was very much
limited to organizations who used
computers
but in the late 80s internet happened
and then
we had e-commerce coming in which
basically led
to our online retail stores online
banking and
online data stores as well which then
led to
criminals hijacking this data or
hijacking your money
and trying to steal it on the internet
itself in 2001 cyber criminals launched
attacks against
ebay yahoo cnn amazon and other
organizations
2007 this was where one of the biggest
bank hacks had happened swedish bank
nadia they recorded at least a million
dollars
being stolen in three months from 250
accounts
2013 adobe had 2.9 million accounts
compromise
and their usernames and passwords
released on the open internet
in 2016 kaspersky one of the leading
antivirus providers to the world
reported around 758 million malicious
attacks
that occurred which they identified
themselves these are some of the most
famous faces in cyber security or
earlier
cyber crime in 1988 robert
morris uh he's an american computer
scientist
and entrepreneur he's best known for
creating what is called the morris worm
and this was way back in 1988
and this is the first computer worm that
has been identified on the internet
kevin lee or kevin lee polson in 1990
uh he was accused of hacking into
a los angeles los angeles radio station
called kis hyphen fm where
there was a contest going on and if
you're a particular number of caller
and give a correct answer you're
supposed to win a porsche 944
and he hacked the those telephone lines
ensuring that he became that particular
person
and answered the question correctly uh
it was later on
revealed that this actually happened he
was jailed for it
then comes david smith david smith
he created the melisa virus now melissa
virus
one of the most dynamic viruses known
around march
1999 that's when this happened this
virus was released
and this was a macro based virus which
affected microsoft world and outlook
based files
adam bought bill in 2004 he's also an
american computer hacker
from michigan he gained unauthorized
access to
love's computer corporate computer
network via an open
unsecured wireless access points uh now
these access points back then were not
that much secured uh the these people
were able to identify it
what they tried to attempt by doing that
was gain access to the company's network
and install the software which would
then help them capture credit card
information
of that organization right and this was
later on identified as well
and he was prosecuted for that crime and
got
jailed just a matter of trivia kevin lee
polson
he was one of the first people found
guilty and was
banned from using computers and the
internet for three years after his
release
in today's world we cannot even imagine
living without the internet
this guy lived for three years without
it now let's see how cyber security
works
uh it's all about securing a computer
and there are various methodologies
there are various
factors that come in on how you're going
to secure uh various aspects of the same
computer
we start off by authentication
mechanisms what is authentication
authentication is the part where you're
going to identify a person
authorize that person for some access
controls and
authenticate that person to ensure that
the person is the same person who they
claim to be
so here you start off with a username
and you associate a password with it the
username is used to identify the account
that the person wishes to access
the password is the authentication
mechanism to prove
that the person is who they are now here
you may want to enhance the
authentication mechanism by using a
two-way authentication mechanism
for example with banks when you type in
the username and password
they send an otp or a one-time password
which is auto-generated by a server and
sent to a registered device that the
person
owns for example a cell phone so that's
one
added layer of security where you're not
only relying on the password which can
be cracked
but you're relying on a third-party
device as well which
the person needs to have physical access
to where they're going to receive the
otp
and then they're going to import it
every time they try to log in a new otp
will be generated
securing your passwords just having a
password may not be sufficient
you have to ensure that the password
meets some complexity standards
to ensure that the security of those
passwords or the complexity of that
password
is high enough where cracking programs
will not be able to easily crack the
password
regular updates all the operating
systems or the applications that you
use will be receiving regular updates
could be for functionality
but more for security so as new
vulnerabilities in applications or
operating systems are found out
the software vendors are the developers
of those softwares
over a period of time start sending out
these updates
also called patches to the end users it
is very important for the end users to
identify these security patches
and install them on their devices as
soon as possible
else they remain open for those
vulnerabilities and
unpatched systems that thus can easily
be
hacked usage of an anti-virus to protect
yourself from viruses
worms trojans essentially malwares there
needs to be a software that need
that's installed on your computer that
is going to watch out for them
you cannot rely on the operating system
itself to protect you
so there has to be an antivirus which
will be scanning the connections that
you are making the websites that you
will be visiting
the files that are getting executed in
the background and ensure that
everything
that is happening is legit installing a
firewall on a system or a server
a firewall essentially is a software or
a hardware that allows
or disallows some functionality for
example a port to be opened or closed
or a service to function on a computer
or not function on a computer
thus what you're trying to do here by
disabling unwanted services
is you're limiting the threat landscape
that you're creating for your computer
if a service doesn't exist on your
computer it cannot be hacked
so the essence here is first identify
which ports you'll be using which
services you will be using
and then create a policy on the firewall
to ensure that
only required ports and services are
running
no phishing so phishing as we said could
be a malicious website that is being
hosted by a
hacker the hacker sending you a fake
mail looking like a genuine email
asking you to connect to that particular
server and
fooling you into you giving that
confidential information
to the hacker so you should either the
antivirus or an addition to that would
have a anti-phishing toolbar
which would identify the websites that
you're visiting and
give you the risk rating of that website
uh giving you an idea whether this
website was
ever reported as a phishing website or
not cryptography encryption
the best way to keep everything secure
is to encrypt it however what kind of
encryptions are required
what should be encrypted what should not
be encrypted how that encryption should
function
uh and how this encryption enhances the
business value
is what we need to ascertain so the
knowledge here that will be required
is what protocols you want to encrypt
for that you first need to identify
which protocols you're going to consume
what data is going to be transmitted
over that protocol how
valuable that data is to your
organization and then you're going to
add encryption or cryptography on top of
it to prevent
any attacks from hackers and then
securing dns servers dns
is a domain name server which is
basically an index
that maps your domain names to your ip
addresses
so the domain name system is an index
that maps your domain names to your ip
addresses
now on the internet computers do not
know domain names they only
they can only identify ip addresses and
mac addresses so when we type in let's
say google.com
on our browser the computer doesn't know
what google.com is
what it does is it sends the packet to
the dns server
and in the dns server it queries where
google.com is located it is given the
corresponding ip address
because of which the packet then goes to
the relevant server
there are attacks where a dns can be
compromised and the pointer
pointing to your particular website can
be changed to point to a malicious
server that a hacker is hosting
so to prevent that from happening you
need to secure your dns servers
so with these kind of attacks and the
kind of
defense mechanisms we have seen let's
see how
do we become a cyber security expert so
essentially who is a cyber security
expert a cyber security expert
is an individual employed by an
organization to protect
their infrastructure right so this
person is responsible
to identify potential flaws identify
what threats the organization faces and
then streamline
or create or design or architect
methodology which is going to protect
all the assets that the organization has
so
this is going to happen through a
variety of techniques such as
finding weaknesses so vulnerability
management where
you run vulnerability scanners identify
potential flaws
in uh the organization's infrastructure
could be applications could be servers
could be desktops could be operating
systems uh could be anything could be
network-based flaws as well
and then you're going to monitor these
systems you're going to
look at the data flow that is going to
the internet
through the network to the intranet
rather and then you're going to check if
there is anything malicious going on
in that network so over these techniques
you're basically going to monitor it on
a day-to-day basis on a regular basis
and you're going to try to identify if
anything
out of the ordinary is happening right
after you find the weakness
you're going to test those weaknesses to
identify the complexity of those
weakness
to validate those weakness actually
exist and then you're going to repair
them
you're going to patch them you're going
to install updates
or you're going to prevent you're going
to install mechanisms
like firewalls or antiviruses to
mitigate those
weaknesses and you're going to thus
resulting in strengthening
the areas where an attack may have
occurred let's see
the domains in cyber security now when
we say domains in cyber security
in the previous slide we were discussing
where these attacks may happen like
applications infrastructure
network so let's see these domains in
details
asset security now when we say assets
assets could be
applications could be networking devices
could be computers
could be routers it could be wireless
access points
uh and these uh all these devices have
their own operating systems they have
their own functionality
and it is important that we look at the
security of each and every
asset that the organization owns
security architecture and engineering
now not everyone can just walk in an
organization
and then say let's start implementing is
uh in implementing security in a
particular manner
we have to standardize the security in
such a way
where the security is constant
for a long period of time and is
consistent right
so for that to happen there is an
architecture an
engineering phase where we are going to
create a plan of how the security needs
to be implemented
for example if i determine to install
a particular antivirus i have to ensure
that the same antivirus is installed on
all the systems in the organization
i cannot have different kind of
antiviruses installed
that do not talk to each other or do not
report properly
to the proper owner so we have to create
policies procedures
and we have to implement them in a
standardized manner for our security
to work properly communication and
network security
now with cloud computing coming in and
hybrid clouds happening where you got a
deployment of a physical infrastructure
talking to something
that is on the cloud let's say aws or
microsoft azure
right and data flows are happening
globally these days
uh you have to be very careful how these
data are going to be transmitted across
the network
thus you have to create those paths and
ensure that those parts are monitored
properly are regulated properly
and do not have any data leakages
similarly identity and access management
who is accessing my data
are they authorized to access my data
and if yes
how am i going to authenticate them how
am i going to track them home how am i
going to hold them accountable for
whatever they have done even if a person
is authorized to do something
we have to hold them accountable for
that activity so that if something
something happens later on we can
identify who made that change
so the identity and access management
module will consist of
us creating groups policies users
roles and interlinking them with the
assets
to ensure that only authorized people
are able to access those devices
security operations on a day-to-day
basis we need to monitor the security
of the organization for example if today
i
start facing a denial of service attack
or somebody starts a password attack on
my organization where
uh they're trying to crack somebody's
password there should be some internal
mechanisms that are in place
which will try to identify these attacks
one the appropriate administrator
and that administrator will walk in and
try to
investigate that attack so day-to-day
operations are a must
security assessment and testing now that
we are all have these
mechanisms in place are they going to
remain constant
for the rest of our lives no i.t is ever
evolving scenario
so we need to assess and test our
security controls on a regular basis
to ensure that there are no gaps left
what i configure today
may be irrelevant tomorrow so i have to
constantly keep on looking at the latest
security trends
the latest vulnerabilities that are
being identified the patches that are
being installed
and i have to compare my infrastructure
to all of these to see that i
am compliant with the latest security
standards software development security
so if you're an organization who's
developing software and who's going to
sell that software to end users
security becomes a huge part because the
end user or the buyer
if it's an organization is going to ask
what kind of security testing was done
in that application
so that brings us to a software
development life cycle which
a life cycle which talks about how
you're going to create that code
how you're going to test that code
ensure that the code is secure enough so
you need to follow secure coding
practices
and you're going to test the software
over and over again till you're
satisfied with the outcome
and then security and risk management
now uh when we come to
risks risks are basically events that
may occur compromising the security of
an organization
so it is very important that we identify
these risks we map these risks
we verify how that risk is going to
impact the business
and then try to figure out security
controls to mitigate that risk or
bring it down to manageable aspects so
that's a lot of talk
that's a lot of domains that's a lot of
attacks that we have discussed
now let's see what kind of courses and
certifications are available
for us to enhance our careers and
address all of these domains
all of these attacks so starting off
from a technical perspective
where we are going to look at ethical
hacking or security where we are going
to
assess and do a liberty assessment and
penetration test there are
certifications from compchia like
security plus or from ec council which
is the certified ethical hacking
training
which basically allows us to become
vulnerability assessment and penetration
testing experts
so we'll be technically testing each and
every device
and trying to hack those devices to see
if that
vulnerability is real and what can be
attained out of that vulnerability
cissp is very high level is a very high
level certification
that normally is considered as a
management level certification
right so just to get certified yourself
you need at least five years of
experience in the i.t security field
uh this is where you get certified and
you're basically a chief information
security officer
where you're going to develop policies
procedures
and security control mechanisms and
you're going to standardize the security
policy of the entire organization
then you've got the cisa or also known
as the csa
certified information systems auditor it
is from an
asaka it's more on the system side where
you're going to audit systems and you're
going to verify that they are adhering
to
the policies that you have implemented
the cism or system
is a certified information security
manager this is again
a project-based oriented approach where
you're going to
manage the security of an organization
and you're going to look at all the
daily operations
of the security operations center and
you're going to maintain and manage
all of those functions overall when
we've talked about risk assessment and
risk strategy for that we've got the ca
crisc which is a certified in risk and
information systems control
now for these certifications this is
more on the business side of everything
where you understand the business
processes you understand the business
requirements
and based on those business requirements
you compare the technical
implementations of compute of computing
powers that you have implemented
and then you are going to compare how
those technical aspects can be converted
into a risk
for example a vulnerability assessment
identifies
a possible sequel injection attack now
technically it becomes
technically it becomes a big risk
however which system is
are being affected if that system gets
compromised what kind of losses is the
organization looking at
how much are they going to be what kind
of losses the organization are looking
at are they looking at lawsuits from
their customers are they looking at
penalties from regulatory authorities
so that risk that implied risk that this
if this vulnerability is hacked that is
the
aspect that you want to look at when
you're looking at risk information
and controls similarly you have ccsp
this is
a certified cloud security professional
certification
so this is especially for people who
want to deal with the cloud uh let it be
a public
cloud a private cloud or a hybrid cloud
this certification gives you an
architectural overview over
different aspects of cloud and how you
want to implement security
in a cloud-based scenario so simplylearn
offers
all of these certifications with
trainings from
certified professionals so there's a
master's program from simplylearn
which talks about becoming a cyber
security expert
which includes all of these trainings
once you have these kind of trainings
uh and you get those certifications on
your profile that's where you're
basically a cyber solutions or cyber
security expert and
you'll be designing and developing
security policies
structures architectures for various
organizations and helping them
enhance the security of their
infrastructure so
let's see what we have talked about
during this entire video
first what is cyber security and its
advantages we have talked about
the confidentiality integrity and
availability triad and we have talked
about the threats
that are posed for the cia triad motives
behind cyber crimes
we have seen what motivates people to
attack other computer systems
and steal data from it we have talked
about types of hackers and cyber
security experts so we've talked about
white hat black hat and grey hat hackers
there are other
types that we have talked about as well
we have looked at the domains that are
available in cybersecurity
and the courses and certifications that
can be mapped with these domains
so this is what uh what we have
discussed within this session
uh if you have any further queries
please go ahead and post them in the
comment section
and we'll try to address them as soon as
possible
with this i thank you for going through
this entire video
and again i'll wait for your comments
and i'll respond
respond back as soon as possible thank
you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here